on Tuesday all 435 seats in the House of
Representatives are up for election
Democrats need to flip at least 23 seats
in order to gain control of the house
for the first time since 2010
Republicans find themselves on the
defensive of the 66 most hotly contested
races the GOP is defending 60 of the
seats in the Senate the Republicans hold
a narrow 51 to 49 CH but Democrats find
themselves defending 26 seats including
10 in states won by President Trump in
the 2016 election meanwhile voters in 36
states will be electing a governor on
Tuesday that includes too closely
watched and fiercely contested races in
Florida and Georgia let's get some
insight on the election for that we turn
to fill a bump national correspondent
for the Washington Post Phillip good
morning let's talk about I mean
traditionally in a midterm election
turnout is down that's right but but but
in early and absentee voting were
actually in some states seeing a huge
acceleration and voting aren't we that's
right and it's sort of hard to read what
that means right now first of all we're
contrasting 2014 which is which was one
of those low turnout midterm elections
so it's a little easier to get more
turnout but also we're seeing an
increase in early voting in general
anyway right and so I looked at this
last week most of those people who are
early voting are people who vote all the
time anyway and they may not be going to
vote early because it's more convenient
to do so right it's hard to say what
that means at this point in time and
we'll really be able to evaluate that
better after Tuesday when you say hard
to say what it means you mean for which
party that may serve more right exactly
I mean I searched in voting generally
speaking is going to be beneficial to
the Democrats one of the reasons
Republicans typically do well in midterm
elections is because Democrats don't
turnout as heavily for a variety of
reasons a boost in turnout generally
will benefit the Democrats but again
it's hard to see how much of a boost
we're going to see Republicans are
voters in particular seem to like what
they're hearing on the on the trail
particularly from the president what our
democratic voters seeking to hear from
their candidates well the Democratic
Party Democratic candidates put a heavy
focus on health care this election cycle
one of the things we're seeing is that
really is the thing that's capturing
people's attention that's what people
are interested in hearing about as well
I think President Trump has
very effectively changed the
conversation to a large extent to
immigration in a way that I think he
thinks will help energize his base but
it really healthcare is the thing that
we've seen both Democratic candidates
talking about and what people are really
sort of focusing on as they're thinking
about their vote we heard the president
concede that he might lose the house
though the Republicans might lose the
house how is that looking at this point
the house 23 seats the Democrats need it
seems pretty likely the Democrats will
take the house because it is structured
in a way that it's gonna be beneficial
to them there's a lot of Republicans
that retired this year there's a lot of
Republicans who won in in years like
2014 2010 which were big Republican
years and so they sort of stretch
themselves a little too thin right so
there's some seats the Democrats can
pick up which is the opposite of what's
happening the Senate the Senate is very
much favorable to the Republicans
Republicans are likely to at least hold
their majority if not gain on it so it's
sort of a fascinating dichotomy on
Tuesday it seems like midterms are
always a referendum on the president is
it even more so is that fair to say in
this election it's very fair to say
Gallup actually released data on Friday
which shows that the number of people
who say that their vote is meant to
support or oppose the president is the
highest among both parties since 1998
which is when they first started doing
it there's a lot of people are going out
to vote because of presidents from for
good or bad how about voter suppression
I want to hit on this just how much
should might that impact what is taking
place across this nation from the new
voter ID laws to election polling places
closing or or essentially keeping voters
away from the polls right well this is
also something that's pretty contested
is the effect that you can have with
order suppression we saw there was a
study that was done that I think showed
something like a hundred thousand people
in two states Kansas in Tennessee in
2012 or prevented from voting because of
new voter ID laws that made it harder
for them to go out and cast ballots
obviously this is something that is has
in certain states being a strategy to
try and tamp down on turnout
particularly from voters are more likely
to vote Democratic it's hard to say at
this point though what the effect is
going to be we've looked at this in
Georgia Georgia obviously state where
this is being closely watched and again
it's one of the things that we're gonna
have to sort of come back after the fact
and say how much of an effect of this
happen all right Phillip bump we
appreciate the insight it's ours to go
now not
and CBS News will have live coverage of
the midterm elections on Tuesday
beginning on our streaming service CBS n
at 5:00 for central and stay with CBS 4
complete election night coverage
starting at 8:00 7:00 central